hi there Steve coffin here today I want
to talk about something that I think is
very important and I want to sort of
initiate a discussion I want to hear
comments from people maybe one day we
can have a discussion over Skype with
someone who has a different perspective
on this today I want to talk about the
basics and how we learn the basics
because so often we hear that you know
we have to master the basics and you
know and let's maybe go step back I
think if we look at language learning
there are basically two tasks in my
opinion one is to learn a lot of words
because we need words in order to
understand and express ourselves and the
second task is to understand how the
language works the structure of the
language that sometimes referred to as
grammar so the people who sort of prone
the idea of you know let's first master
the basics
I presume they're talking about the
basics of the structure of the language
and some of the basic vocabulary now
I've also spoken in the past about sort
of big picture learning learning the big
picture and the nuts and bolts so to
some extent again the basics are sort of
them nuts and bolts so how do we acquire
these basics in my view and I'm going to
refer to my experience with Arabic it is
impossible to master the basics upfront
it is impossible to begin with the
basics that is one of the major faults
of conventional language instruction
whether it be trying to teach you
certain structures in the language and
then expecting you because you do
certain drills with these that you're
going to master them I think that's
wrong
even in terms of vocabulary so many
books start out with things like colors
why are colors basic we don't know the
vocabulary you're gonna need is going to
depend on your interest but the fact is
you're going to need a lot of vocabulary
and in my experience the basics of the
language don't start to make sense we
don't even have a chance of learning
them until we have acquired
a lot of words and it's been exposed to
a lot of the language through as you
heard me say before input activities so
if I look at my Arabic learning the sort
of first invitation to learn Arabic was
when I was at the polyglot conference in
Bratislava I met a gentleman who worked
with icy mill in Germany and I was
chatting with him and I his name is
Philippe I think yeah he'll correct me
if I'm wrong I said I looked it up
beforehand and he said this is the best
book and and I had said one of the
obstacles to me was the writing system
and he said well this is a great way to
learn it so I bought the US email system
from him he gave me a bit of a break I
looked into this book and I just found
it overwhelming I couldn't read the
Arabic writing they introduced the
letters one by one there was a lot that
it not to mention the fact that it's
written for German speakers and so
therefore the kind of collet
romanization the pronunciation is for
German speakers so they have no way of
showing the the t the the and thought
sounds in Arabic so they used some funny
combination of German that was further
confusing then on top of that to
introduce some niceties of the grammar I
left this book just left it at home
didn't even bother with it but I'll come
back to it and that's what I'm going to
talk about later on here so then I had a
quick overview of No then my friend
Judith Mayer who's a great polyglot she
suggested I try her book which I went
through learn to read Arabic quickly
master a new alphabet well you don't
quickly master any of the basics in a
language you start to get introduced to
these things I didn't with all due
respect to Judith and I think it depends
on how you learn and many people love
this book I just couldn't do it because
the letters were taught with reference
to names of countries cognates think
that we're familiar with so if we see
the name
Cambodia and then we see that written in
Arabic and that's gonna help us learn
the letters I didn't find that I just
couldn't do that I didn't want to look
at a bunch of names of countries and
cities and stuff like that so this
didn't help me what I found eventually
was that I just had to get in the
language and so as those of you who have
been following you know that I
downloaded some tables of the letters of
the Arabic alphabet and slowly
painstakingly started reading I found
out that I could actually type quite
easily on my iPad in Arabic so that
after a while I started getting closer
and closer to you know a sense of what
these letters were because they appear
in different forms I mean it was
difficult and it continues to be
difficult and but at least now I can
kind of read and of course I listen and
so I have read I can remember the
statistic twenty or thirty thousand
words in Arabic I have listened to a
hundred hours of Arabic 9100 I can
remember I have listened to these sixty
many stories that's been my main
activity just about the only thing I do
I listen to them thirty forty talent
times some of them lessons one to twenty
I know quite well twenty to thirty quite
well thirty to forty bit of a struggle
forty to fifty a little more difficult
than 50 and Beyond is even more
difficult but I know because I have
overcome the difficulty of the first ten
and the first twenty and then the first
thirty that I will eventually get to the
sixty and there is a lot of vocabulary
there and Allah essentially all the
basic structures of the language are
there and I have heard them but in
hearing them and in reading there's a
lot of stuff that I don't notice so and
a lot of stuff that I wonder about why
does it you know go this way I know what
the story means in fact and this is a
suggestion one thing that's very useful
to do after you have read this I read
the story in Arabic and I've saved words
and phrases to my database at
used some words and phrases there's
still a few issues relating to tents etc
that a little bit fuzzy
then I listen to the story typically if
I'm on my stepper at home and I read the
translation because all of these stories
have English and not only Incas are
translated into many languages so I can
listen to the story which I listened to
before many times which I've read in
Arabic and now I can listen to it and
read it in English and that helps
clarify certain things about that story
so that when I next listen to it I have
a better sense of what's happening not
only the meaning but also the structure
of the language then I then went back to
my a Samia book and struggled with their
funny romanization struggle with some
other things but what they do in this
book is the introduced the basics so now
they go through explaining some of the
endings of words some of the tenses some
of the you know prepositions what we
would call prepositions which often are
slammed together with the word in Arabic
and how all of that works and so as I do
that then I get a better sense now I can
cope with the basics because I have a
point of reference I've been listening
to and reading all this stuff so I can
have a bit of a sense just an almost
intuitive sense of how the language
works I have a lot of words I can now
read that was another thing when you
start into for example even this book
which I glossed over the first time all
the examples they give you are in Arabic
so if I'm not that comfortable reading
in Arabic that's a block right away I
should add by the way that some of the
books I bought on Arabic the Arabic
script is so small that it's ridiculous
as a learner you want larger script
another advantage of learning on an iPad
is you can adjust the font size at any
rate
now that I can read Arabic when they
give some example verbs I can actually
read it comfortably plus I've seen the
verb and different verb forms in
different texts that I've been listening
to and reading so when I read an
explanation in here it actually makes
sense the same is true of course whereas
you
and whereas this is a summary and I very
much recommend getting short summary
grammars to refer to from time to time
so that you can regularly refresh and
get that overview of the grammar this is
a summary where as with us Emil they
give you sort of explanations as you
proceed now the disadvantage with us
email is a lot of their content at least
I'm up to less than 25 is largely
uninteresting random sentences it
doesn't matter but it gives you some
explanation about their grammar
explanations that I have either
intuitively felt experienced or I have
had questions or things that I simply
didn't notice now after going through 25
lessons on Ozzy mill I go go back to my
lessons at link my mini stories and as I
listen and as I read I focus now on some
of these column basics that I'm now more
aware of that I know this better and as
I noticed um you know I'm mining the
same content that I've listened to 30
times that I've read 5-10 times I'm
mining it again with an emphasis on the
basics and now I see it I see it now one
final thought language learning is not
not a 100-yard dash
okay you don't master something right
away so I'm in no hurry I have no idea I
have no I haven't spoken Arabic
essentially so I'm gonna start speaking
when I reach 3,000 note words I don't
know what will come out but as I noticed
these structures better I think I won't
do too badly and so so I guess that the
the key point here is that and I didn't
mention pronunciation but the same is
true of pronunciation where they talk
about the basics of pronunciation until
you have heard a lot of the language
trying to refine your pronunciation I
think is very difficult once you've
heard a lot of it they
some of these basics whether it be
pronunciation grammar etc you're now
getting this specific call it
instruction against a background which
is the big picture that you have already
absorbed and therefore things start to
become clear whereas the attempt to
teach these basics up front too early at
least in me creates resistance I can't
read I don't know what you're talking
about
I don't know enough about the language
so the message here is the basics we
have to go back there over and over
again
we might start with an overview but then
get into the language get words into you
get experience with the language and
then go back to the basics and then with
this renewed sense of what happens in
the language go back to more input more
reading and listening and then again you
can review the basics that to me isn't
how we learn the basics and whatever we
learn in languages we forget so we
learned the basics we forget the basics
we learn the basics we forget the basics
that's how it works
anyway thank you for listening I look
forward to your comments
[Music]